PRESENTER 1: This
block of stores
was located at 84 Massachusetts
Avenue, across the street
from MIT's main entrance.
One of MIT's many connections
to public television,
this is where Boston station
WGBH first went on the air
in 1955.
The building had previously been
the home of a roller skating
rink, and the wooden floor,
bumpy from years of moisture,
posed a challenge for
cameras dollying across it
and made creaking noises.
Nonetheless, in the six years
at the MIT campus location,
WGBH alumni say, this is where
many successful careers were
launched and important
broadcast work
developed, including simulcasts
on radio and TV of Boston
Symphony Orchestra concerts,
with some early ones taped
at MIT's Kresge Auditorium.
After a fire in 1961
destroyed the studios,
WGBH moved to other locations.
MIT President, James Killian, was
a leader in the development of WGBH
and played other important roles in the early days
of educational television, including
as chairman of the National Commission on
Educational Television and later, director
of the Corporation for Public Broadcasting.
FITCH: Hello, I'm John
Fitch, MIT science reporter--
PRESENTER 1: In the
1960s, John Fitch
hosted the Science
Reporter television series
broadcast, produced
jointly by MIT and WGBH.
A pioneering effort at having
scientists explain their work
to a general
audience, the series
was another MIT/WGBH
connection, which
had been encouraged
by President Killian.
FITCH: Dr. Harold
Edgerton, a professor
of electrical measurements
in the Department
of Electrical
Engineering at MIT.
A man who was both an
inventor and a teacher
and internationally famous as
the father of modern high speed
photography.
FITCH: The way it worked was
that WGBH called me and asked
me if I'd be willing to-- would I like to try out for this MIT
Science Reporter program.
And I thought, yeah, that sounds really interesting.
Over the next four years, we did just about
100 half hour programs.
PRESENTER 1: MIT's
relationship with WGBH
came into play again when
in 2012 Kresge Auditorium
was host of an MIT produced
performance documentary.
PRESENTER 2: Next, an
orchestra of students from one
of the world's great science
and engineering universities.
PRESENTER 1: A film featuring
the premiere performance
of Awakening by the
MIT Wind Ensemble.
WGBH Boston aired the
program the following year,
and it went on to
win an Emmy award.
So in this part
of the MIT campus,
where WGBH had its start, to
where the Stratton Student
Center is now, we
come full circle
to remember where a piece of
broadcasting history was made.
[MUSIC PLAYING]